donate please do
information do that it's also on our
website as well some great advice being
an experienced hiker from washington
state i thought i knew a lot but they
have some great advice that i didn't
even know you should be different in the
desert right yes completely different
one of the things i always say is
communicate where you're going
specifically for your loved ones
sometimes people don't do that it's a
major oversight and a lot of times
people go on and if they get lost they
kind of keep moving around what they
tell what they told us was stay put
because there's gonna be people coming
through that trail you'll run into it
aaron ralston the guy who had to cut off
his own arm to survive
he told nobody where he was going yeah
so the problem nobody could find him no
great advice there again go to our
website to check out all that guys
outside right now we've got to deal with
some wins still thankfully you remember
yesterday
this camera you couldn't even see the
mountains or the strip today looks a lot
better air quality still hasn't improved
too much right now we're still in the
moderate range for air quality but at
least we're out of that dust warning and
until healthy readings for dust 73
degrees official high for the day today
you're telling yourself that is way
below normal and you're right because 86
is where we should be we're only in the
70s today 105 the record that was back
at 2018 not too long ago currently
outside with 67 for centennial hills 70
for you in spring valley 74 for north
las vegas 74 also whitney ranch
mountains edge 69 spanish trail included
76 for henderson and anthem right now
you're at 71 degrees outside of town 70
for prompt 73 for boulder city and 83
for latham remember on saturday death
valley was a triple digits that's how
hot it was over the weekend right now
we've got those high thin clouds
overhead that are starting to clear out
look at this some snow in the sierras
right now as that system exits to the
north there wind forecast does show
however some breezy winds still around
tonight and also overnight we'll calm
down just a little bit but unfortunately
tuesday more wind is on the way with
even stronger wind we expect on
wednesday specifically later on in the
day and we're also going to see a big
temperature drop with also warmer
temperatures later on the week into next
week in fact it's going to feel like
early spring for the first half of the
week and then by the time we get to the
weekend into next week it's going to
feel like early summer look at the
temperature difference from those 70s
back to our first triple digits that we
haven't seen in quite some time
53 tonight overnight breezy evening will
feel chilly in the morning with 53
degrees because we've been mod lately in
those 60s for our morning temperatures
74 for tomorrow cool and breezy we'll
see partly sunny skies again for
tomorrow 70 still below normal for this
time of the year across the valley and
even outside of town two look at prophet
71 death valley only 83 tomorrow here's
your eight day forecast now like we said
winds will be turning i think the
strongest wind day this week again is
going to be on wednesday and then we
warm up to the triple digits next week
like i said the last time i checked last
time i had triple digits on my eight day
forecast was september
okay look at this it's been that long
the high is the same as the low later in
the week yes that's crazy welcome to our
eight day in the desert
you know what is with sports is whenever
you bring